today i'm gonna make a case to you why i
believe getting a prenuptial agreement
may be one of the best thing you can do
for your marriage and by the way
if you're watching this and you're
saying what the hell is he talking about
just praise for impact take a deep
breath watch this video together there's
a likelihood you're going to argue
afterwards but if i do make sense to you
in this video before you argue
give it a thumbs up and subscribe to the
channel so let's get right into it
so stick around to the very end i'm
going to give you a lot of different
stats and eight reasons why you ought to
consider getting a prenup but let's get
right into it so look i've been running
a business for 20 plus years business is
very hard right i've been in the
insurance space over two decades the
whole concept about insurance isn't
buying auto insurance because you're
gonna get into a car accident you don't
buy a life insurance because you're
gonna die tomorrow you buy auto
insurance that in case you get into a
car accident or somebody hits you you're
protected you buy life insurance that in
case you die tomorrow or next week or
next year while you have a wife or a
husband and kids they're at least taken
care of the same thing as goes with
insurance it's the same thing that goes
with prenup look at prenup agreements or
post-nuptial agreement as a form of
insurance so now let me give you some
stats when it comes down to marriage and
divorces so
only five percent of folks who get a
divorce had a prenup of the people that
got a divorce 15 of them wish they would
have set up a prenup so now when you
look at these stats and divorces in
america
41
of first marriages end up out of divorce
but watch what happens to the stats 60
of second marriages and 73
of third marriages which means if your
first marriage didn't work out and you
didn't have a prenup fine but don't do
it on your second or your third so now
let me continue a few other things you
need to know when it comes down to
marriage the average marriage in america
lasts eight years and aside from that
every 16 seconds somebody gets married
in america and every 42 seconds
someone's getting the divorce in america
so now pre-nuptial nuptial government's
pat i don't get it are we talking about
divorces here today let me give you one
of the most important reasons why you
ought to get a nuptial agreement it's
simply to avoid future arguments for
example
most of the time when you talk about why
why would why would somebody get an
upshot grandma do you not trust me it's
the famous line when somebody wants to
set up an option you must not trust me
you don't trust me my mom told me you
don't trust me all you care about is
money if somebody starts saying stuff
like that that's a very deep concerning
thing because what do you mean i don't
trust you we've only known each other
for two years we've only known each
other for a year nowadays most people
get married online most people meet each
other online i don't have the same years
of experience with you if i would have
met you through a family member or a
friend or co-worker there is a lot of
risk today in marriage more than ever
before because people are more than ever
marrying somebody that they know the
least amount where before at least we
knew more about the person that we're
getting married so having said that i'll
give you two stories and i'll get into
the two points so jackie o john f
kennedy's a wife
she's widowed okay so while she's about
to re while she's about to marry onassis
who's a very successful businessman at
the time i think he's a billionaire very
well known very successful
and he has always liked jackie they
finally agreed to get married and one of
the clauses jackie gets to put in the
agreement the nuptial agreement is for
each year that jackie is married to him
if he divorces her she gets 10 million
dollars that's part of the agreement she
was able to negotiate a lot of different
things so was he he had great attorneys
she had great attorneys so we get
married look i'm a first lady if i'm
going to risk marrying somebody like you
there's risk for marrying a playboy like
you i got to be protected
per year i'm married to i get 10 million
bucks now that's that time by the way 64
65 65.66 compared to today that's a lot
of money right summer hike is another
one she gets married to a billionaire
okay i believe they had a kit together
and i even believe there's a there's a
contract in their agreement that per kid
it was a certain number 17 million
dollars i don't remember the exact
number but there's something there now
somebody may say oh my god look that's
fake that's not real love what do you
call that is that real love that's not
real love the way i got married was real
love oh really yeah okay because you
don't
think about the fact that life happens
after we get married after you have one
kid two kids three kids four kids travel
in-laws issues you and i cannot predict
that the other person's gonna change or
not you can't predict if i'm gonna
change and i cannot predict that you're
gonna change of course we're loving each
other we're getting married but then
life happens and marriage sometimes
turns into a business and then there's
money so now eight reasons to why set up
a prenuptial agreement one of them for
me prevent future arguments what do i
mean by this well when getting married
you know i try to teach this from people
that i've watched very closely and
people that i you know consult with is i
like to have three different accounts
one account is our account okay and our
account the money is spent to pay the
bills the money spent for our kids the
money spent for our food it's everything
that's our then there's her account then
there is his account right
her account she wants to go buy three
louis vuitton purses it's your money do
it you want to go spend money on one of
your cousins that i really don't like
and she always asks you for money and
instead of you asking me for the money
you don't even have to ask me anymore
you just give your cousin 10 000 out of
your money but not my money and not our
money instead your money because when
it's your money it's a different story
now when when birthday comes up
if you don't set it up this way and say
your wife buys you a gift or your
husband buys you a gift out of our money
it's not really a gift you're like oh
babe here's what i got for you yeah babe
i saw it on the credit card the other
day i kind of know what you were getting
me and it's not like you felt the real
pain because you're spending it out of
our money right but isn't that how it's
supposed to be well if i buy it out of
my money it's very different if she buys
it out of her money it's very different
because she's like you know watch you
got this for me this is awesome babe and
i'm telling you from somebody who has
lived this like what i'm telling you is
how i live my life it feels amazing when
it's coming out of her money and feels
amazing when i buy her something out of
my money so number one prevents future
arguments number two protect separate
property what does this mean so let's
just say if hypothetically we're getting
married and prior to getting married she
owned three properties i never bought
those properties those are her
properties they're not my properties no
problem hey babe the nuptials were
giving me those properties i bought
before we got married matter of fact one
of them was given to me through my dad
that's my property okay and whatever we
do together is going to be ours but
these three properties are my property
you're writing a nuptial agreement she's
right those properties i never bought
she bought and it's my property
fantastic you signed a vice versa if
it's his or if it's hers well you know
that company i was running that company
before and i'm just telling you that's
company is going to be mine so here's
how it's going to be set up this is my
company i was building a way before you
okay that totally makes sense and these
collectibles and this art that i had
this collectible card i have whatever it
may be you write it out on whatever it
was personal property assets so it's
separated nobody can fight and bicker
over it later on number three say you
marry somebody who's coming with a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars of
debt
if you don't clarify that that's
officially both your debt but if you put
in an optional agreement and say listen
that 150 000 of debt that's your debt
that's not my debt that is your debt and
that's in our agreement this is your
debt no problem i totally get it i'm
willing to marry
babe 150 000 of debt i didn't have it a
day before i got married i don't want to
all of a sudden get a 150 000 credit
card debt it's too much pressure on the
marriage it's too much pressure on me
i'll choose to help you out if i choose
to help you out but i don't want to be
forced to have to handle that 150 000
okay fine no problem you write it out
it's in place both parties know we're
good to go number four is revolving
around issues having to do with children
from prior marriages so
say you get married hey this is our son
it's my stepson it's i'm gonna treat him
like my son
but that's also your son from a prior
marriage how do we want to handle some
of the finances these are your two kids
how do we want to handle this the man
may say i'm going to take care of my own
kids okay then we don't even need to put
that in a nutshell agreement but no
these are my kids okay then the
responsibilities with your kids if they
do xyz financially this is on you or
this is on me i got five kids you got
two kids is it fair for you to have to
support all the five and all this stuff
there's well no the other three are
living with the dad the other two are
living with the mom you know whatever it
may be but that's gotta be in the
nuptial agreement so it doesn't create
future uh arguments when my dad didn't
get remarried one day i'm sitting down
with him i said why don't you ever get
remarried he says i did not want to have
to have the new wife create issues with
my existing kids that i have with the
two of you i have a great relationship
with you i did not want to have more
issues with you so i dated but i never
got remarried sometimes kids from prior
marriages can cause a lot of friction
and one person can say it's a magical
question you ready who do you love more
me or your kids what does a parent say
what do you mean who do i love more you
i'm your wife you don't love me
i had your i had my kids before
you don't even want to have that
conversation you write it out you put it
in there it prevents future arguments
number five the benefit of setting up a
prenup now is you're preventing yourself
from overpaying later on to legal fees
so everything's on a piece of paper
while you're sitting there and you know
what's going to be happening because
later on here's what lawyers are going
to do you ever seen the movie wedding
crasher where vince vaughn was a divorce
attorney and he would sit there and you
can tell hey you're pushing back and
forth pushing back and forth the longer
a divorce drags out the more lawyers
make money and you better believe the
two people that are on the same team
behind closed doors wink wink is his
lawyer and it's her lawyer because all
they want to do is lengthen more fights
so it's more billable hours the more
money they make but when you come to a
lawyer and say hey
we already have this agreement in place
oh shoot these guys
instead of having to spend fifty
thousand dollars in legal fees and
divorce fees they spend five thousand
dollars by setting up a prenup up front
these guys were prepared for it not
saying you're gonna get a divorce but
later on if it does get to that point
you will save yourself tens of thousands
of dollars of legal fees point number
six child expenses that you guys are
both going to have together not prior
marriages but your child so save for
instance you have three kids okay so
what's going to happen who's going to
pay for college tuition for the kids
who's going to pay for health costs
that's expensive are you going to pay
for it are you going to structure it
that way sometimes you'll notice you
know hey if we have three kids two of
them live with me one of them live with
you i pay for 66 percent of college you
pay for a third okay sounds good what if
the husband they have three kids and
then all of a sudden there's a divorce
that takes place but the wife stays
single she's not cohabitating with
anybody maybe the husband supports but
if the wife gets married and is
cohabitating with somebody well then
that man's got to take care of the stuff
maybe i will only help 50
all of those details are easily written
in a nuptial agreement on how you want
to handle college
expenses close per year school tuition
you know any of that stuff you can put
in the nuptial agreement number seven is
alimony so you can you can write it in
there and say look if i'm the
breadwinner you're not if i'm raising
your three kids what about income i have
not been working for four years so my
market value has dropped how am i
protected to get an income that's a very
good argument so you got to put it down
i totally understand if that does happen
here's what we would do you know
depending on what income i'm making at
that time i don't know what income i'm
going to make what if we lose everything
what if i file bankruptcy it has to be
different based on the amount of money
that i have in the amount of money that
i make you can't put me in a corner you
know put me in a corner where i'm going
to be following bankruptcy losing
everything and i have to live in a
one-bedroom apartment because 90 of my
income is going to everything has to be
written in a way
that neither the income earners getting
destroyed nor the individuals that's
taking care of the kids it has to be
fair to the party based on the current
financial situation they are
when the potential divorce happens point
number eight is to protect your
inheritance let's just say you come from
a wealthy family
your dad your mom they have money 50
million bucks 100 million bucks 10
million bucks a billion dollar whatever
the number may be say look
i'm protecting against this because
sometimes the parents want you to get an
upscale agreement because they're
concerned that the spouse may be trying
to get to that money so in many cases
family may say we'll fund your wedding
but you have to have a nuptial agreement
and in the agreement your inheritance
going to your grandkids of course some
of that has to do with trust and how you
write your living trust but in the
nuptial you can protect yourself to say
whatever inheritance i'm getting from my
family that's coming to me not to i can
give it to the kids but it's to me and
the kids not to you whether it's the
wife who's married to who's got a family
that's wealthy or the husband that is
also sometimes written in an upshot
agreement i'm gonna give you a bonus
point it's not really one of the a but
the bonus point is you can update your
nuptial agreement every five years say
you're married and you're like you know
what
he helped me a lot with my company that
i was running before him i think he
deserves 10 equity in the company
i think she deserves 10
she's actually helped me grow that
company hey i want to change it up what
do you want to do i want to give 10
percent the company to because without
you the company would have gone to where
it's at right now that's awesome
it actually works the other way as well
the more the person's earning trust of
you or the other you can choose to
adjust an optional agreement there is
nothing wrong with that you can do that
at any point because both parties are
now working to say look the whole
purpose of nuptials says look man i
really want to be with you i'm telling
you i'm fully committed i'm in it
i'm not with you for your money i want
to build a life with you that's what i
want to do okay and i cannot believe the
last five years life wouldn't be where
it's at without you so guess what let's
change it up that happens all the time
as well i've done this myself but that
happens all the time as well when it
comes down to an optional agreement so
now
if you're still watching this
and your husband first watched it then
he said babe i think you should watch
this video and see what pat has to say
or if you watch and said babe you told
your husband i think you need to watch
us together
and some part of it right now is like i
don't know if i agree with him on that i
don't know if i agree with him but i
agree what he said there i'd agree what
he said
my entire mo
with nuptial agreements
is to prevent future arguments
marriage is very
very very hard
but to be married and to have a kid is
very hard let alone two or three or four
then throw an in-laws throw health
issues throw travel through taxes throw
finances through a market change through
people getting fired throw all of those
things in there and say hey go ahead
make your marriage work no wonder
first marriages divorce ends up at 41 of
marriages ended about a divorce no
wonder second is 60 third marriages are
73 because it's hard but if we do it
right up front we got a fighting chance
of making our marriage worth so two
things if you do want to get the pdf of
today's episode click on the link below
in the description you'll be able to get
it and on top of that if you enjoyed
this topic this video i've got another
one i want you to watch it's a video i
shot maybe five six years ago titled
15 things to know before dating an
entrepreneur
click here to watch that take care
everybody bye bye bye bye
[Music]